Від самого початку пандемії активісти пацієнтських організацій допомагають лікарням та хворим.
Часто їхня допомога - це питання життя або смерті для сотень українців, які почуваються кинутими напризволяще державою.
Невеликий офіс ущент забитий медичним обладнанням. Це приміщення благодійного фонду "Свої".
І тут - без перебільшення - щодня рятують життя "ковідних" пацієнтів.
З маскою все зрозуміло, єдине що в упаковці вона ось так буде..
За статистикою МОЗ, нині в Україні розгорнуто майже 34 тисячі ліжок з подачею кисню, з яких 18 тисяч - вільні.
Чому ж тоді через брак місць у лікарнях пацієнтів, хворих на "ковід", виписують навіть з низьким рівнем кисню в крові?
Дзвінок з Черкащини.
Лікарю кажіть, що він чекає, поки буде апарат, і щоб не думав Вас виписувати, поки Ви в такому стані.
Інакше Ви викличете поліцію… І ми вам відправляємо.
- Дякую!
- Добре? Алло?
- Я вже плачу…
- Ні, Ви не плачте, Ви йдете до лікаря. Домовилися? Будь ласка, не плачте…
І щодня таких дзвінків співробітники фонду отримують десятками.
Виходить, що у міністерстві не бачать або не поінформовані про реальну картину захворюваності, звітуючи, що все під контролем?
Ви знаєте, що не можна лаятися в ефірі… Навіщо ви запитуєте, як я оцінюю ситуацію.
Так і оцінюю, як не можна сказати в ефірі. З одного боку, МОЗ нічого не зробив, щоб не допустити такої ситуації.
А з іншого - головні лікарі рапортують в МОЗ, що все добре, і бояться кари на свою голову.
І всі живуть у мильній бульбашці, що все добре. Правильно організований локдаун вирішив би частину проблеми.
Але у нас так не роблять, на жаль.
У нас постраждають ті люди, яким нічим буде кормити родини.
Якщо говорити дуже цинічно, то без локдауну ми втрачаємо літніх людей і людей із хронічними хворобами,
про яких особливо цинічні особи скажуть - вони б і так померли.
Коронавірусом більше, коронавірусом менше…
У фонді кисневі концентратори видають пацієнту, а не лікарням.
Прилад розрахований для домашнього користування.
Але часто-густо такі прилади можна побачити саме в лікарняних палатах, де не вистачає кисневих точок на всіх хворих.
На прохання самих лікарень прилади закуповують благодійники, як, приміром,  "Пацієнти України".
У цьому фонді сподівалися, що критичної ситуації, яка  склалася навесні, уже не допустять.
Адже було створено "ковідний" фонд і установи мали достатньо часу, налагодити систему державних закупівель та підтримки лікарень.
Останні місяці я щодня отримую дзвінки від лікарів, що в них знову немає масок, немає респіраторів, немає базових засобів захисту.
Причому лікарів хворіє дуже багато. І ми почали думати: що ж таке? Куди все це поділося?
Провели аналітику невелику і проаналізували, що МОЗ закупило за весь час епідемії 6,5 мільйонів масок,
мільйон двісті респіраторів і 18  тисяч 500 рукавичок. І порахували, що цього вистачає респіраторів на 9 днів, масок на 15 і по одній рукавиці на лікаря...
Тож, ми зрозуміли, чому лікарі до нас телефонують. І ми закуповуємо засоби індивідуального захисту і відправляємо по всій Україні.
І знову місяць у нас абсолютний дурдом. Те, що відбувається на рівні міністерства сьогодні, - це просто абсурд.
Логіки в цьому немає. У міністерства сьогодні є гроші, багато грошей, є "ковідний" фонд.
Але на сьогодні не використано навіть половини. Чому так трапилось - невідомо.
Місяць тому фонд завершив косметичний ремонт у лабораторії Центру громадського здоров’я.
Вона перевіряє роботу всіх обласних лабораторій, що тестують COVID-19.
Коли я побачила першу лабораторію, я не спала дві ночі.
Сумно вони виглядають, і там велика кількість інфікувань серед співробітників.
Там є перебої з електрикою. Це лабораторія, де є машина, що роблять ці тести,
і з холодильниками, де зберігають реагенти. І там регулярно пропадає світло - це нормальна стандартна історія для лабораторій по Україні.
Ми зробили невеликий ремонт. Це крапля в морі. Перегородки зробили, щоб перегородити зони безпечні і небезпечні.
Але це крапля в морі. Чому МОЗ не робив цього всі ці 8 місяців? Чому не взяв вибірку лабораторії, які мають бути ключовими, і не відремонтував їх?
Благодійний фонд "Пацієнти України" не припиняє і своєї основної роботи:
вже дев'ять років він працює як місток між МОЗ і важкохворими пацієнтами та стежить, аби держава виділяла достатньо коштів на їхнє лікування,
особливо нині, коли основна увага прикута лише до коронавірусу.
Закупівлі в цьому році усіх ліків дуже затримали.
Вони мали початися в січні-лютому, але реально почалися лише влітку.
Спершу міністром була пані Скалецька, потім Ємець, потім Степанов.
І кожен казав: я нічого не знаю, треба розібратися. І знову ж таки гроші є, механізм закупівлі.
Але в нас є МОЗ, в якого немає політичної волі це робити.
Методички з рекомендаціями для лікарів і пацієнтів в умовах пандемії, поради, як самостійно реабілітуватися після коронавірусу.
Цілу низку інформаційних програм Національної служби здоров’я допомагають здійснювати активісти благодійної організації "100% життя".
Інертність держави тут пояснюють тим, що епідемія співпала з реформою медицини.
Приміром, 1 квітня, під час пе  ршого локдауна, стартувала програма медичних гарантій.
Ми опинилися просто у фантастичній ситуації, коли в нас реформа стартує.
Коли немає розуміння до кінця між усіма суб'єктами, як це все має працювати.
Коли не побудовані до кінця елементарні реєстри. А тут ще й "ковід".
Фонд також закуповує обладнання для лікарень.
Зокрема вісімнадцять опорних медзакладів в тринадцяти областях отримали обладнання,
що дозволить оцінювати ймовірність розвитку дихальних ускладненнь хворих на "ковід".
Те, що я спостерігаю щодо роботи департаментів охорони здоров'я в певних областях:
часто буває так, що кошти поступають частинами,
їх вистачає лише на ситуативні точкові рішення, і вони так їх і вирішують на місці.
Цього не достатньо для того, щоб вибудувати системні рішення. Недостатньо, щоб побудувати автономну кисневу станцію,
яка буде трохи дорожча, ніж закупити балони. Але пізніше вона буде давати постійно кисень, а балони закінчаться.
Мабуть, це криза управління.
Утім, це важко прийняти родичам хворих.
Особливо коли ті помирають, бо в лікарнях елементарно бракує приладів для кисню.
Коли мені зателефонувала мама і сказала, що вона вже класно і що тітка-лікар, теж добре, але в бабусі немає запахів, я впала на підлогу і ридала.
Я вже не можу... Я розумію, що нікуди подзвонити. Лікарні переповнені, кисню нема, хочеш щось робити - роби сам. І ми це самі зробили…
Я можу боятися і що з цього зміниться?
Я фільтр не поміняю, якщо руки будуть трястися.
Чи у мене з'явиться сервіс, який буде цим займатися? У мене немає а ні сусідньої кімнати а ні сервісу.
Теоретично я могла б одягти і рукавиці, і маску. Але по факту на цю дівчину не вдягнеш нічого, і спимо ми разом і цілодобово разом…